ce soir ce soir 60 % de nos concitoyens
ayant plus de 60 ans auront été vaccinés
en première injection
une stratégie donc de sortie progressive
et phase et dont les éléments seront
présentées par le président de la
république très prochainement ce
vendredi plus précisément cette
perspective d'un retour progressif à une
vie plus normale doit tôt ainsi nous
amener à revoir nos outils juridiques et
à les adapter à une situation qui à
compter du mois de juin prochain ne sera
plus celle de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
mais devra nous permettre de répondre à
ce que j'appellerais un devoir de
vigilance sanitaire
nous donnons également la capacité d'une
réaction rapide en cas de nouvelle
accélération de l'épidémie soit à
l'échelle du pays soit à celle d'un
territoire particulier c'est pourquoi le
projet de loi relatif à la gestion de la
sortie de crise proposera au parlement
d' instituer un régime transitoire
dis donc de sortie de crise sanitaire
courant du 2 juin au 31 octobre prochain
notre intention
avec la mise en place de ce régime
transitoire est de nous permettre
d'accompagner le processus de
réouverture par des mesures adaptées à
l'évolution de la situation dont nous
pensons qu'elle va continuer à
s'améliorer progressivement
mais également de disposer des outils
nécessaires dans l'hypothèse où
l'épidémie connaîtrait des situations de
rebond